obviously I got to ask you a little bit
about Game of Thrones how is it compared
going back to shoot season five today's
previous four seasons season five
not just for Aria but for the whole
story is a very strong one and there are
scenes that I've gone through in red
this year for arias storyline and four
other storylines that I've just been I'm
so so excited to see and being part of
such a massive kind of machine I don't
get to be on set for a lot of scenes
that are shot so just to see how they're
going to do it and I principie like
usually I read the scripts and I keep it
to myself and then I you know go on and
shoot my bits but this year like every
director I'm like what are you going to
do for this bit like you know this bit
that's in your episode how are you going
to shoot that are you going to do with
this and is that bit going to be real
are you going to see to you that or and
I've just literally anyone that I can
find I've been asking questions all the
makeup people and all the prosthetic
people like how are you going to do this
bit and it's just so so exciting and
I've never been so engrossed into like
the scripts as I am this year and yeah
like after last year's finale I'm I
can't I can't wait for the new year and
that sounds so so weird being part of
the show that you're such a massive fan
of but as the show's picking up and
getting more intense for every storyline
I honestly I'm such a massive fan you
sound like a little director in the
making yeah I mean one day maybe I don't
think I could ever handle something as
massive Game of Thrones but I'd love to
do like a little indie thing what can
you tease the people out there he was
kind of dying for next year to come
round for IO storyline aria in the new
season
she makes a big change very early on
which is you know usually you're excited
for sort of like episode 9 or episode 10
for your story and it's really great bit
but that doesn't happen till episode 7
or this year from from episode 1 you
know people for me I couldn't stop
flicking for arias scenes and that's
really really exciting when you get
people's attention from like the
beginning yeah that's what I'm looking
forward to so
a big change in aria from from the start
and it doesn't happen gradually like it
has over the other years I mean if you
could like react to tell me how you
reacted when you saw some of the big
scenes in season 4 like for example
Oberyn Martell vs. the mountains that
was pretty strong stuff how did you feel
when you watched that on screen I was
absolutely amazed and I'm like every
time you think Jesus I just did a really
hard stunt scene like I'm so great a
sword fighting you watch a scene like
that and you just like oh my god but uh
so so brilliant and I know that day was
really hard and Pedro on set they were
shooting that in Croatia and I'm at the
end of shooting like he was his final
bit and he like run ran and like jumped
in the ocean and like that's really
really cool
but totally like I can see why that was
a long long day for the both of them and
um ya know looked amazing and like
sometimes you just I wish that you could
have been there for when they shot it
but then it's also great to have that
like you know you read it on paper and
you watch it on screen and just see how
it kind of infuses everything it's great
and brands storylines talk about family
and he's been told that you know about
the flying you will fly I mean what do
you think that means and and do you
think walking could run in the family
yeah I mean in the books I know the
walking runs throughout the Starks um so
I was like I can't wait from you know
Arya to walk into Nymeria and then I'm
area like left in episode 2 or 3 of
season 1 yeah and uh that's really
really exciting and I think last year
brand storyline really really picked up
and people for a long time we're
questioning where it was going to go and
then after last yeah they've realized
that you know bran can be an extremely
strong contender just because he doesn't
have his legs doesn't mean that he can't
do other things and that's what I love
about the show is that you every time we
think how you rule that person off he
hasn't got any legs like it takes a
massive u-turn and all of a sudden ya
know I'm excited for it and um yeah I
think for a cast member as well that's
really exciting when you get a scene
like that you're not sure where they're
going to take it but um it's going to be
somewhere really really great well I
hope so because the Starks are really
not
in much luck at the moment we heard that
Tom Letitia
he played Jack and her car is gonna be
returning looking forward to working
with him again
ah that's been rumored yes uh you have
to wait and see yeah and Gendry
hopefully we're gonna see him because
we've missed him for a whole season
haven't really exactly yeah Joe wrote a
really funny state as last year like a
tweet just saying still Rowan and I love
that so yeah again she's just still
Rowan about somewhere but I think we
will see him again we have to see him
again he's such an iconic you know after
episode 2 of season 3 I think we
realized a lot about him and that he's
very very powerful person he doesn't
really know it yet so either he's got to
turn it around and you know use himself
or someone else is going to manipulate
you